The angle between a vector and itself is 0 degrees. The dot product computes
the cosine between 2 vectors, times the length of each vector involved. The
cosine of 0 degrees is 1, but the length of the vector is not necessarily 1, so
the dot product itself is not guaranteed to be 1. This statement is false. If
the vector was stated to be normalized, this statement would be true. If two
vectors are perpendicular, they are 90 degrees apart. The cosine of 90 degrees
is 0, so this statement is true. The cross product of two vectors computes the
sine of the angle between the vectors, expressed as the length of the resulting
vector. This sine can vary from negative 1 to 1, so the length of the resulting
vector can also vary in length. If the two normalized vectors are
perpendicular, the length is always 1, but not at any other angle. This
statement is false. The angle between the vector and itself is 0 degrees, so
the sine will be 0, meaning the resulting vector will always be length 0. This
statement is true.